we had an initial sort of blast if you
will within about a week of the micron
shooting it has been up three hundred
percent dropping this case is usually
full it's our best selling guns in right
and now we're just going to spread them
out to make them look full the
difference between now a typical
November for us is it this is hunting
season so normally we fell hunting
shotgun hunting rifles a lot of
ammunition and accessories right now
it's one hundred percent personal
defense firearm and this has been a very
popular home detention they're very easy
to learn to shoot and also that the
universal sound everybody seems to think
that's a big deterrent but it's
definitely a clear signal with that
homeowners got a gun or a good customer
service you know we ask the person what
are gonna use the gun for because we
want to fit you with the perfect gun so
one hundred percent of the people have
said well you know what's going on I
need to defend my home but the key thing
to remember here is that law enforcement
isn't going to be able to protect each
and every household there's not enough
police out there to ensure safety to
each and every person
shadi what I'm going to take you out
there shoot the Smith & Wesson in a t20
to the most popular one that we sell
okay I'm filming I'll awesome fuck keep
your gun pointed downrange